[inaudible]
WELCOME.
SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO ITEM
NUMBER TWO WE DO NOT YET HAVE A
QUORUM SO WE'LL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
WE HAVE.
A NUMBER OF RESOLUTIONS TO BE
HEARD TODAY SO WE'LL START WITH
ITEM NUMBER TWO AJ ARE.
FORTY TWO GREAT HANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I AM PROUD TO INTRODUCE AJ ARE
FORTY TWO A RESOLUTION DECLARING
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE TITLE TEN
PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA.
AND URGENT OPPOSITION TO THE
RECENTLY PROPOSED GAG RULE WHICH
WOULD AFFECT TITLE TEN
PROVIDERS.
ADMINISTERED BY THE FEDERAL
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES THIS PROGRAM SERVES
FOUR MILLION PEOPLE A YEAR.
IT IS THE NATION'S PROGRAM FOR
AFFORDABLE BIRTH CONTROL AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE.
THE PROGRAM IS AND HAS BEEN
AVAILABLE TO HELP ENSURE THAT
EVERY WOMAN EVERY PERSON
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY LIVE.
THEIR INCOME OR BACKGROUND OR
WHETHER OR NOT THEY ARE INSURED
[inaudible]
HAS ACCESS A BASIC HEALTH CARE
AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
INCLUDING BIRTH CONTROL CANCER
SCREENINGS STD TESTING AND
TREATMENT [inaudible]
IN CALIFORNIA.
TITLE TEN PROVIDERS.
REPRESENT 25%.
OF THE PATIENTS NATIONWIDE ARE
LET ME REPHRASE THAT TITLE TEN
PROVIDERS IN CALIFORNIA SERVE
25%.
TITLE TEN PATIENTS NATIONWIDE.
THAT IS ONE MILLION PATIENTS WHO
ARE SERVED BY PROVIDERS IN OUR
STATE THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS TRYING TO CENSOR.
THROUGH THIS PROPOSED TITLE TEN
GAG RULE.
SO TO FURTHER EXPLAIN THIS
THREAT TO CARE IN OUR STATE I AM
JOINED BY ANDREA SAN MIGUEL WHO
IS OUR PUBLIC POLICY ADVOCATE
FOR PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU WITNESS PLEASE THE
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
--
AGAIN MY NAME'S ANDREAS TO ME ON
THE POLICY ADVOCATE FOR P. PAKA
REPRESENTING A HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN HEALTH CENTERS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA --
ALONG WITH OTHER TYPES OF
CLINICS AND PROVIDERS PLANNED
PARENTHOOD HEALTH CENTERS MAKE
UP A LARGE PORTION OF THE TITLE
TO NETWORK THROUGHOUT OUR STATE
--
AS HE SOMEONE WOMAN MENTIONS I
TELL TIMES CREATED IN --
NINETEEN SEVENTY AND ALL OF THE
BASIC SERVICES THAT HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED --
SINCE THEN THROUGH THIS PROGRAM
INCLUDING --
PREVENTION SERVICES HAVE LET --
THE UNITED STATES IS CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING A THIRTY YEAR LOW
FOR UNPLANNED PREGNANCY.
AND A HISTORICAL LOW FOR TEEN
PREGNANCY THANKS IN LARGE PART
TO THESE TYPES OF PREVENTION
SERVICES --
BASED ON ITS SUCCESS TITLE TEN
HAS HAD WIDESPREAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT --
FOR DECADES YET DESPITE THESE
OUTCOMES AYE AND HOW MANY LOW
INCOME PATIENTS RELY ON SUCH
SERVICES THE CURRENT FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION DID PROPOSE A
TITLE TEN GAG RULE --
EARLIER THIS YEAR THIS RULE
WOULD PROHIBIT CLINICIANS --
SO DOCTORS NURSES ANYONE --
REALLY WHO WOULD BE --
GIVING CONSULTATION --
ON THEIR OPTIONS TO OUR PATIENTS
--
FROM GIVING REFERRALS TO
PATIENTS ABOUT ABORTION OR EVEN
TALKING ABOUT ABORTIONWITH
THEIR PATIENTS --
WHICH WOULD PREVENT THESE
PATIENTS FROM GETTING FULL AND
HONEST MEDICAL INFORMATION FROM
THE DOCTORS AND NURSES THAT THEY
TRUST.
THIS RULE BUILDS A WALL BETWEEN
MEDICAL PROVIDERS AND PATIENTS
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE.
AS NOTED IN OUR WRITTEN COMMENTS
TO THE ADMINISTRATION --
THE IMPACT OF THIS RULE WOULD BE
MOST DEVASTATING FOR LOW INCOME
PATIENTS WOMEN ESPECIALLY WOMEN
OF COLOR WHO ALREADY FACE
SYSTEMATIC BARRIERS TO ACCESSING
HEALTH CARE INCLUDING PREVENTION
CARE.
THIS IS AN IRRESPONSIBLE
PROPOSAL BY THE ADMINISTRATION
WHICH IS WHY THEY WERE MORE THAN
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND COMMENTS OF
OPPOSITION.
THE CAME FROM CALIFORNIA ALONE.
AND WE WERE VERY APPRECIATIVE
FOR THE COMMENTS PROVIDED BY PRO
TEM UM ATKINS AND SPEAKER RENDON
AS WELL AS SUB SEVERAL OTHER
LEADERS IN THE LEGISLATURE --
AND SO TODAY WE URGE YOUR
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT --
FOR AJ ARE.
FORTY TWO PLEASE JOIN US IN
ASKING THE ADMINISTRATION TO
REEVALUATE.
THIS AND ANY PROPOSED RULE THAT
WOULD ENDANGER WOMEN'S HEALTH --
HERE FOR ANY ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE ABOUT
THE PROGRAM THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE AND
SUPPORTS.
ALRIGHT CNN IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
NO WE DON'T HAVE QUORUM AT SO
NUMBERS.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU WAS COVERED A
FEW MAKE CLOTHES.
THANK YOU I JUST WANT TO ADD
THAT THE OF THIS RESOLUTION --
ENJOYS A FIFTEEN CO AUTHORS FIVE
OF WHOM ARE SENATORS TEN OF WHOM
ARE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE -- AS
WE WORK AS A STATE --
TO RESIST THE INAPPROPRIATE
DISCRIMINATORY RACIST AND SEXIST
PROPOSALS.
THAT WE HAVE SEEN COMING FROM
THIS FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION --
AND THE CONTINUED ATTACK ON
WOMEN AND WOMEN'S RIGHTS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
WE WILL TAKE THIS UP WHEN WE GET
A POOR [inaudible]
THANK [inaudible]
MISS RUBIO. FOR THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR I'M PULLING ITEM
NUMBER SIX HR.
ONE THIRTEEN AUTHOR OF THE
CONSENT TO GENDER SO THEY COULD
BE HEARD.
SINCE THIS WAS ON INCENTIVES NOT
GONNA HAVE ANY.
PROBLEMS GETTING THROUGH SO I'D
APPRECIATE IF YOU'D BE BRIEF I
DO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS --
TODAY I'M HERE TO PRESENT HR ONE
THIRTEEN KNOWN AS PICKY AS
RESOLUTION TO COME OUT
COMMANDMENT COMMEMORATE THE LIFE
OF PEAKY AND MANY CHILDREN LIKE
HIM.
WHO HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES AT THE
HANDS OF AN UNFIT PARENT OR
THOSE WITH RIGHT TO CUSTODY AND
TO DRAW ATTENTION TO THE
IMPORTANT THE IMPORTANCE OF
CHILD SAFETY CUSTODY DISPUTES?
AND MEDIATION.
ON APRIL TWENTY OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN VICKI DISAPPEARED
AFTER A TRIP TO DISNEYLAND.
WELL UNDER THE CARE OF HIS
FATHER.
WHO HAVE BEEN AWARDED
UNSUPERVISED VISITATIONS DURING
A LONG ONGOING CUSTODIAL
DISPUTE?
MONTH MONTHS AFTER PEAK IT'S HIS
APPEARANCE AND INTENSE
INVESTIGATIVE WORK DETECTIVE
APPREHENDED BECAUSE FATHER.
AS THE MAIN SUBJECT WHO LATER
CONFESSED TO MERCK MURDERING HIS
OWN CHILD.
AND DISCLOSE THE WHEREABOUTS OF
HIS REMAINS.
DURING THE CUSTODIAL DISPUTE.
THE FAMILY COURT SYSTEM
REPEATEDLY REFUSED TO GIVE AYE
MUSCLE CUSTODY.
DESPITE MOUNTING EVIDENCE THAT
THE KEY WAS IN DANGER.
I'M NOT FOUGHT FOR HER SON.
THE DOCUMENT THE DANGER WAS
IGNORED AND THEN DISMISSED.
MISTER CHAIR THE REASON THAT I
ASKED FOR IT TO BE PULLED OUT OF
ON A OFF OF CONSENT IS THAT I
WANTED ANNA.
AS THAT IS BECAUSE MOTHER TO
ITEM BE ABLE TO SPEAK TO YOU.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE
ANA WAS BECAUSE MONTH.
THANK YOU.
FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN STONE AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
EXPRESSING HOW HONORED I AM TO
BE SPEAKING HERE ON BEHALF OF MY
SON.
I SIT BEFORE YOU AS A MOTHER.
AS A VETERAN OF THE UNITED
STATES ARMY.
AS A FORMER ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
PRINCIPAL.
BUT ALSO AS AN ADVOCATE FOR
CHILDREN.
AND ADVOCATE FOR CHILDREN WHO
SUFFER AT THE HANDS OF AN
ABUSIVE PARENT.
AND CHILDREN WHO FALL VICTIM TO
OUR COURT SYSTEM.
MY PURPOSE HERE TODAY IS TO
SHARE MY PERSONAL TESTIMONY TO
RECOGNIZE THE CRITICAL ROLE THAT
US CALIFORNIA LEADERS PLAY IN
THE LIVES OF OTHERS.
AND TO PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR YOU TO REFLECT ON HOW THE
MURDER OF AN INNOCENT CHILD.
CAN INFLUENCE THE WAY YOU CHOOSE
TO SERVE YOUR CONSTITUENTS IN
THE FUTURE.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT AT
LEAST FIFTY THREE CHILDREN HAVE
BEEN MURDERED IN CALIFORNIA.
SEVEN OF THOSE CHILDREN WERE
RESIDENTS OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
WHERE I RESIDE. THREE CHILDREN
HAD THEIR THROATS SLIT BY THEIR
MOTHER.
THE FOURTH CHILD WAS TORTURED TO
DEATH BY HIS MOTHER AND HER AND
HER BOYFRIEND.
IT WAS.
EIGHT THE FIFTH CHILD WAS
MURDERED BY VEHICULAR
MANSLAUGHTER HE WAS TEN DAYS OLD
WHEN HIS FATHER INTENTIONALLY
RAN HIM OVER.
CHILD NUMBER SIX WAS RECENTLY
MURDERED BY HIS MOTHER AND
STEPFATHER HE WAS TORTURED TO
DEATH BY HIS PARENTS.
AND THE LAST CHILD MY SON.
I MUST ADDRESS THE ON THE
SECOND.
LOVINGLY KNOWN AS SPEAKING.
WAS MURDERED BY HIS FATHER.
MY EX HUSBAND.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIX AYE BUT I
MET THE MAN OF MY DREAMS AND ONE
YEAR LATER WE WERE MARRIED.
MY WE MARRIAGE LASTED EIGHT AND
A HALF YEARS AND MORE THAN HALF
OF THAT TIME WAS SPENT ON ME
TRYING TO HAVE A BABY.
AND AFTER MANY YEARS OF PRAYERS.
AND FIVE MISCARRIAGES.
GOD FINALLY LISTENED.
AND BLESSED ME WITH THE CHILD MY
ONLY CHILD.
WHEN MY SON WAS FOUR IN APRIL
OF?
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN I TOLD MY
EX HAS BEEN THAT I WANTED A
DIVORCE.
AND ALTHOUGH HE PRETENDED TO BE
DISTRAUGHT.
HE ACTUALLY BEGAN PLOTTING HOW
HE WAS GOING TO HURT ME AND MY
SON.
IN DECEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN I FILED FOR A
RESTRAINING ORDER AGAINST MY EX
HUSBAND.
THE JUDGE WHO PRESIDED OVER MY
DIVORCE CASE WAS GIVEN
IRREFUTABLE EVIDENCE.
DOCUMENTING MY EX HUSBAND'S
HORRIFIC BEHAVIOR.
IN ADDITION TO THE EVIDENCE I
SUBPOENAED THREE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS TO TESTIFY.
ON THE DOCUMENTED LIES IN THE
PHYSICAL ABUSE TOWARD MY SON.
THE FAMILY COURT JUDGE
DISREGARDED THE EVIDENCE AND
RULED AGAINST ALLOWING TESTIMONY
FROM THE THREE OFFICERS.
STATING THEY WERE THERE FOR
CUSTODY REASONS NOT ABUSE.
THE RESTRAINING ORDER WAS DENIED
AND SO WAS MY REQUEST FOR SOLE
CUSTODY WITH SUPERVISED VISITS.
DESPITE REPEATED WARNINGS IN
WRITING TO THE COURT MULTIPLE
REQUESTS FOR SOLE CUSTODY WITH
SUPERVISED VISITS.
I REQUEST FOR A RESTRAINING
ORDER.
AND MY EX HAS BEEN FILING FALSE
ALLEGATIONS WITH CHILD
PROTECTIVE SERVICES.
MY PLEASE FOR MY SON SAFETY FELL
ON DEAF EARS AND THE VOLUMES OF
EVIDENCE THAT I PROVIDED TO THE
COURT WERE IGNORED.
ACCORDING TO THE HOMICIDE
DETECTIVES EVIDENCE SEIZED
DURING THE CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION SHOWED THAT MY EX
HUSBAND BEGAN PLANNING MY SON'S
MURDER.
JUST WEEKS AFTER MY APPEARANCE
IN COURT. FOR THE RESTRAINING
ORDER.
AS OF TODAY.
I HAVE LIVED FOUR HUNDRED AND
NINETY DAYS.
WITHOUT MY PT.
ON APRIL TWENTY FIRST OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN MY EX HUSBAND
SUFFOCATED MY SON.
IN THE BACKSEAT OF HIS VEHICLE
ON MY SON WAS ASLEEP.
STRAPPED INTO HIS CAR SEAT.
AFTER A DAY LONG TRIP TO
DISNEYLAND.
ACCORDING TO THE HOMICIDE
DETECTIVES MY SON AWOKE DURING
THIS VIOLENT ACT.
AND HIS FIRST ATTEMPT AT
SUFFOCATING MY SON FAILED.
AND AS MY SON SAT HELPLESSLY IN
HIS CAR SEAT.
HIS BODY TWITCHING MY EX HUSBAND
PRECEDED TO SUFFOCATE HIM A
SECOND TIME.
AND HERE'S MY SON SWEATER TO DO
IT.
MY SON WAS FIVE YEARS TWO MONTHS
AND TWO DAYS OLD.
MY EX HUSBAND COMMITTED THIS
CRIME.
BECAUSE OF ME WANTING A DIVORCE.
AND TRYING TO PROTECT MY SON.
DURING HIS CONFESSION HE STATED
THAT HE HATED M AND WANTED TO
HURT ME.
AND HE DID.
HE HURT ME IN THE DEEPEST AND
MOST INHUMANE POSSIBLE WAY
POSSIBLE.
ALTHOUGH IT TOOK ME FORTY YEARS
TO BRING MY BEAUTIFUL SON INTO
THIS WORLD.
IT TOOK HIS FATHER APPROXIMATELY
FOUR MINUTES TO END HIS LIFE.
MY NEW REALITY IS THAT I WILL
NEVER SEE MY SON AGAIN.
AT LEAST NOT IN THIS LIFETIME.
AND BEING A SURVIVOR OF VIOLENT
CRIME COMES WITH A LIFE
SENTENCE.
FOR ME THAT SENTENCE IS HAVING
TO LIVE MY LIFE WITHOUT MY SON.
SO I AM HERE TODAY TESTIFYING ON
Y. CHILD SAFETY IS OF SUCH
IMPORTANCE.
MY SON'S DEATH WAS PREVENTABLE.
AND SO WHERE THE FIFTY TWO OTHER
CHILDREN WHO WERE MURDERED IN
CALIFORNIA BY A PARENT.
TRAINING FOR COURT RELATED
PROFESSIONALS IS ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY AND SHOULD NOT BE AN
OPTION.
THE JUDGES AND CUSTODY EVALUATOR
INVOLVED IN MY DIVORCE CLEARLY
MADE UNEDUCATED DECISIONS.
AND JUDGES AND EVALUATORS ARE
PUBLIC SERVANTS WHOSE ROLE.
ACCORDING TO THE LAW.
IS TO PROTECT THE HEALTH THE
SAFETY AND WELFARE OF CHILDREN.
IN MY CASE AS IN MANY OTHERS
THEY FAIL TO UPHOLD FAMILY CODE
THEY FAILED MY SON.
AND UNFORTUNATELY THEY CONTINUE
TO FAIL MANY OTHERS.
IT IS MY HOPE THAT TO RECOGNIZE
THE IMPORTANCE OF PROTECTING
CHILDREN.
AND ESTABLISH A SENSE OF URGENCY
WHEN IT COMES TO TRULY MAKING
CHILD SAFETY A PRIORITY.
NOTHING I DO WILL EVER BRING
WAIKIKI BACK.
AND I PERSONALLY HAVE NOTHING TO
TO GAIN BY BEING HERE TODAY.
AS I HAVE ALREADY LOST.
WHAT WAS DEAR TO ME?
BUT I DO THINK HERE BEFORE YOU.
BECAUSE I DO NOT WANT ANOTHER
PARENT. TO EXPERIENCE THE HORROR
AND HEARTBREAK THAT I LIVE EACH
AND EVERYDAY.
SO WHAT YOU CHOOSE TO DO HERE
TODAY COULD MAKE A DIFFERENCE TO
THOUSANDS.
YOU CAN CHOOSE TO SAVE INNOCENT
LIVES AND PROTECT CHILDREN WHO
SUFFER AT THE HANDS OF AN
ABUSIVE PARENT AS MY SON DID.
YOU CAN CHOOSE TO BE THE LEADERS
THAT OUR CHILDREN YOUR FUTURE
CONSTITUENTS NEED YOU TO BE.
I THINK YOU FOR YOUR TIME YOUR
COMPASSION AND YOUR LEADERSHIP.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A QUORUM SO
HONEST HOURS KWAK'WALA REFLECTS
STONE HERE [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM CHAU [inaudible]
CHIU HOLDEN [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN REYES.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN STONE AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M KATHLEEN
RUSSELL THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CENTER FOR JUDICIAL
EXCELLENCE.
THE CALIFORNIA NONPROFIT THAT
ADVOCATES FOR JUDICIAL
ACCOUNTABILITY AND CHILD SAFETY
IN FAMILY COURTS I SPEAK TODAY
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
OF HR ONE THIRTEEN WHICH HONORS
THE LIFE AND SPIRIT OF ANNAS
FIVE YEAR OLD SON.
OUR ORGANIZATION COLLECTED DATA
ON P. KIAN FIFTY TWO OTHER
CHILDREN WHO WERE MURDERED BY
DIVORCING HER SEPARATING PARENT
HERE IN THE PAST DECADE.
THEY ALL DESERVE TO LIVE LONG
AND PROSPER LIVES YET NONE OF
THEM WILL GET THAT CHANCE.
MANY OF THESE HOMICIDES
INCLUDING P. KEYS WERE
PREVENTABLE IF FAMILY COURTS IT
PRIORITIZE CHILD SAFETY OVER
OTHER BEST INTERESTS FACTORS.
WHEN DETERMINING CUSTODY AND
VISITATION?
AND OF COURSE PROFESSIONALS WERE
TRAUMA INFORMED.
THE THREE SIMPLE CHANGES
PROPOSED IN THIS RESOLUTION OF
FOCUS ON CHILD SAFETY.
ACCESS TO JUSTICE THROUGH COURT
REPORTERS AND TRAUMA INFORMED
PROFESSIONALS WITH EXPERTISE IN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND CHILD
ABUSE.
WE'LL SET CALIFORNIA FAMILY
COURTS ON A CRITICAL PATH TOWARD
RECOVERY AND TOWARD CHILD
PROTECTION.
ONCE AGAIN CALIFORNIA IS POISED
TO LEAD THE COUNTRY ON IMPORTANT
POLICY REFORM.
FROM THE CHAIRS CRUCIAL AB
TWENTY FORTY FOUR TO THE TWENTY
EIGHT CALIFORNIA HOUSE MEMBERS
WHO AGREED TO CO SPONSOR ARE
SIMILAR CHILD SAFETY MEASURING
CONGRESS.
WHICH NOW HAS SEVENTY CO
SPONSORS FROM TWENTY STATES.
YOU'RE I VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION
INSURERS CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP
ROLE IN PROTECTING CHILDREN IN
FAMILY LAW.
AT BOTH THE STATE AND FEDERAL
LEVELS.
WE CAN DO BETTER WE MUST DO
BETTER AND WITH YOUR PASSAGE OF
HR ONE THIRTEEN WE WILL ENSURE.
THAT THE SENSELESS MURDERS OF
PEAKY.
ALECIA [inaudible]
WHY IT [inaudible]
SARAH SOPHIE [inaudible]
GIULIANA [inaudible]
JULIAN.
MADELEINE.
AND ALL OF THE OTHER INNOCENT
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN WHO FAMILY
COURTS DID NOT PROTECT.
WERE NOT IN VAIN.
NO OTHER PARENT SHOULD EVER HAVE
TO ENDORSE SUCH PAIN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU JUST GIVE US YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION PLEASE
CALIFORNIA CONNIE VALENTINE FROM
CALIFORNIA PROTECTIVE PARENTS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
AND THANK YOU.
KATHERINE CAMPBELL REPRESENTING
ALL THOSE CHILDREN WHO SURVIVE
AND THEN HAVE TO LIVE WITH THEIR
ABUSER TO THE H. OUT.
SUPPORT THIS THINKING.
JONES SOLARI SAN MATEO COUNTY
RESIDENTS PROTECTIVE PARENTS UP
THE JUDGE WHO FOUND MY ULTIMATE
TAKE ANY TALK ABOUT EACH IS THAT
YOU SUPPORT THE BILL YES SUPPORT
REP.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
OF THE RESOLUTION HR.
ONE THIRTEEN SEEING NONE IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT SINGLE BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CHAO AND THEN.
ISRAEL'S THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
JUST WANT TO START BY THANKING
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
RESOLUTION FORWARD.
ARE I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
WITNESSES FOR BEING HERE TO
SHARE HER STORY ODDNESS BE VERY
DIFFICULT. TO TELL THE STORY ALL
AGAIN BECAUSE I YOU WERE IN MY
OFFICE NOT LONG AGO AND I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR SHARING.
ARE IT IS VERY MOVING STORY AND
ONE ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN BRINGING THIS
ISSUE FORWARD.
OUGHT TO OF OUR HIGH IKE TO A
TO LEGISLATORS WITH SOME OF THE
ISSUES ARE SELLING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER S..
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR MOST
ESPECIALLY THANK YOU. FOR
BRINGING PICKY STORY TO US
[inaudible]
BECAUSE THAT AS DIFFICULT AS IT
IS IT THIS IS HOW WE KEEP HIS
MEMORY GOING --
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY
KNOWS THAT WOULD HAPPEN TO HIM
SHOULD NOT HAVE HAPPENED.
WE KEEP REPEATING HIS NAME SO
THAT WE REMEMBER HIM.
SO IN HONOR OF PICKY I
ABSOLUTELY WILL MOVE THIS.
MOVES CLIMB OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION IS
OUR SECOND.
AND THE SECOND BY MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
ALRIGHT SEEING NONE THROUGH VERY
MIKLOS.
I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS AND CHILD
ABUSE IS SOMETHING THAT
TRANSCENDS THE ECONOMIC DIVIDE.
AFFECTING BOTH PORN RICH
COMMUNITIES THAT HAS NO CULTURAL
OR H. DETERRENT FROM ITS
DAMAGING EFFECTS.
AS A MOTHER.
A FAMILY MEMBER OF A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVOR.
IT IS CRUCIAL THAT WE ENSURE
THAT THE SAFETY OF OUR CHILDREN
CHILDREN HAS A PRIORITY.
OVER [inaudible]
ANY [inaudible]
OTHER ISSUES.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT FOR ME AS A
MOTHER TO SIT HERE AND ARM TO
LISTEN TO WHAT I'M [inaudible]
BUT I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE YOUR WORK MISTER
CHAIR.
ON WITH AB TWENTY FORTY FOUR FOR
THE COMMITMENT BY THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL TO YOU YOUR LIFE. TEN
MILLION DOLLARS OF APPROPRIATED
FUNDING TO INCREASE COURT
REPORTERS AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND CHILD COULD CITIES.
I WANT PEAK IS MEMORY TO BE A
REMINDER TO ALL OF US THAT WHAT
HAPPENED TO HIM SHOULD NOT
HAPPEN TO ANYBODY.
AND FOR ME.
I ALSO FEEL THAT.
CASES LIKE PEAKY ARE NOT
RECOGNIZED AS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AYE INCIDENTS.
THEY ARE COMPLETELY REMOVED FROM
THOSE STATISTICS AND I THINK
THAT WE NEED TO DO BETTER A
BETTER JOB TOO AND SURE THAT.
THE COMMUNITIES KNOW THAT THE
CHILD ABUSE THAT IS BEING --
CONDUCTED IN THESE --
VIEWS OF HOMES IS ALSO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SO I THINK YOU FOR YOUR
OF YOUR SUPPORT AND APPRECIATE
--
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR THEIR COMMITMENT
OUGHT TO MAKE SURE THAT PEAK IS
MEMORY OF CONTAINS THANK YOU.
I THINK THAT I AS FOR YOU I PUT.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION TO
SECOND THE MOTION IS THAT THE
RESOLUTION BE ADOPTED.
KALRA PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM CHOW.
CHOW AYE CHU.
CHU AYE HOLDEN [inaudible]
KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN REYES
[inaudible]
REYES I THE NEEDS ONE MORE SO
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER LOVE.
TAKES US TO ITEM NUMBER ONE ACR.
TO SIXTY AND WHILE HE COMES UP
HERE I'LL TAKE A MOTION.
ON ITEM NUMBER TO AJ ARE FORTY
THE MOTION IS THERE SECONDS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT MOTION IS THAT THAT
RESOLUTION BE ADOPTED KALRA
PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM CHAU.
CHAU AYE CHIU.
CHU I HOLDEN KALRA [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN PRESS [inaudible]
REYES I THAT NEEDS TO MORE SO WE
WILL PUT THAT ALSO ON CALL.
PURSUE LOVE I'M NUMBER ONE ACR
TO SIXTY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS A
THE RESOLUTION.
COAUTHORED BY ALL EIGHT LGBT
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS MEMBERS WITH
RESPECT IN A GENDER NEUTRAL
PRONOUNS AND ENSURING THAT OUR
STATE RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANCE
OF THE STRENGTH OF OUR
DIVERSITY.
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE MORE
INCLUSIVE STATE WITH ME ARE ALSO
INDIVIDUALS TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FIRST WITH US WE GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I'M
MY NAME IS EMILY CHILD.
MAYBE ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA I'M IN SUPPORT OF
ACR.
TO SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO
THE HIGHEST POPULATION OF LGBTQ
INDIVIDUALS IN THE UNITED
STATES.
AND DESPITE CALIFORNIA'S
GENERALLY PROGRESSIVE
NONDISCRIMINATION LAWS
[inaudible]
LGBTQ INDIVIDUALS AND
PARTICULARLY NON BINARY
INDIVIDUALS CONTINUE TO BE
MARGINALIZED AND IGNORED.
IN ADDITION TO BEING SUBJECTED
TO FREQUENT MISUNDERSTANDINGS
AND MICROGRAPHS SHINS.
NON BINARY CALIFORNIANS OFTEN
HAVE TO FIGHT FOR THEIR VERY
RIGHT TO EXIST.
BY CONTINUING TO USE HE AND SHE
PRONOUNS IN STATUTES AND
LEGISLATION.
CALIFORNIA IS TURNING ITS BACK
ON ITS NON BINARY RESIDENTS
WHICH FURTHER ISOLATES AND
MARGINALIZES THEM.
INSTEAD OF USING HE OR SHE BILL
LANGUAGE CAN EASILY BE SHAPED TO
APPLY TO ALL PEOPLE REGARDLESS
OF GENDER.
SUCH AS USING THEY AS A SINGULAR
PRONOUN.
OR REPEATING A NOUN INSTEAD OF
USING A GENDERED PRONOUN.
THIS RESOLUTION IS ALSO IN LINE
WITH RECENT CHANGES TO
CALIFORNIA LAW.
UNDER S. B. ONE SEVENTY NINE
WHICH LEGALLY RECOGNIZES A NON
BINARY GENDER IDENTITY.
THIS RESOLUTION WILL SHOW
CALIFORNIA'S NON BINARY
RESIDENTS THAT THEIR DIGNITY
RESPECT AND RECOGNITION IS A
PRIORITY.
AND WILL ALSO CONTRIBUTE TERROR
A REDUCTION IN GENDER
STEREOTYPING AND DISCRIMINATION.
FOR THESE REASONS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THAT ACR TO SIXTY AGAIN.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS WITH.
AND AS HE WAS HERE ALRIGHT.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR JOHN
MICHAEL FOR EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT THING.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT CNN WILL BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE A MISSILE LOW THERE
WERE SOME AMENDMENTS TO EXTEND
THESE TO THE EXECUTIVE
DEPARTMENTS OF DRAFTING RIGHTS
YOU'RE TAKING THOSE WINDS YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU FOR COMPETITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
EARLIER QUE SO WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECONDS OF
QUESTIONS COMMENTS MR LOW YOU
MAY CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHERE.
THANK YOU THAT MOTION IS THAT
THE CASE HERE TO SIXTY BE
ADOPTED AS AMENDED CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE.
BY STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM CHAU
CHOI CHU.
CHU AYE HOLDEN KALRA.
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN REYES
[inaudible]
REYES I NEEDS TO MORE SOARED
WITH APPLE LA QUINTA VIGOROUSLY
SHAHKOT THANK YOU [inaudible]
MISTER GLAZIER.
THIS TAKES US TO ITEM NUMBER
FOUR SJR [inaudible]
FOURTEEN GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
THAT THAT YOU'RE STONE IN
MEMBERS SAID THIS RESOLUTION
CALLS ON CONGRESS AND THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
TO RENAME ALL FEDERAL PUBLIC
PLACES INCLUDING PARKS BUILDINGS
AND ROADWAYS.
THERE ARE THE NAMES OF ELECTED
MILITARY LEADERS OF THE
CONFEDERACY.
AT THIS RESOLUTION ALSO URGES
CONGRESS TO REMOVE STATUES.
OF ELECTED OUR MILITARY LEADERS.
OF THE CONFEDERACY AND PLACE
THEM IN MUSEUMS WHERE THEY CAN
BE VIEWED IN PROPER HISTORICAL
CONTEXT.
THIS RESOLUTION IS IT'S VERY
SIMILAR TO THE ONE I INTRODUCED
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
IT CALLED FOR CONGRESS TO TAKE
OUT MONUMENTS TO CONFEDERATE
LEADERS I YOUR STAFF ANALYSIS
WITH THAT WHICH IS WHAT.
WONDERFULLY DOT DOES POINT OUT A
COUPLE OF THE CHANGE THEIR IN
THE RESOLUTION THAT RECOGNIZES
THE ONE YEAR ANNIVERSARY --
OF THE CHARLOTTESVILLE BRYANT'S.
AND IT'S AN APPROPRIATE
AMENDMENTS ACT. TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THAT ANNIVERSARY ALSO.
HA HONORS THE THAT THE PERSON
WHO PASSED AWAY DURING THAT --
THAT RALLY AND IT ALSO
RECOGNIZES THE CITY OF
ALEXANDRIA VIRGINIA.
THAT RECENTLY RESPONDED BY
RENAMING JEFFERSON DAVIS HIGHWAY
TO TO TO RICH THE HIGHWAY SO
THERE'S SOME CHANGES FROM.
CLOSE BUT FORWARD AT A YEAR AGO.
UNFORTUNATELY TOO MANY PUBLIC
PLACES IN OUR NATION'S TO HONOR
CONFEDERATE LEADERS WHO SPLIT
OUR COUNTRY INTO IS THE FIGHT TO
PRESERVE THE INSTITUTION OF
SLAVERY.
IT'S BEEN HEARTENING TO SEE THAT
A NATIONAL CONVERSATION ABOUT
THIS.
HAS LED TO SOME INSTITUTIONS
TAKING DOWN SOME CONFEDERATE
NAMES HOW ONE OF THOSE THAT I
JUST MENTIONED.
A BY THE WAY WE HAD TO SCHOOLS
IN CALIFORNIA THAT WERE NAMED
AFTER ROBERT E. LEE --
AND WITHIN THE LAST YEAR HAVE
CHANGED THEIR NAMES THROUGH A
COMMUNITY PROCESS ITSELF --
WE ALSO SEEN SOME PROGRESS HERE
IN OUR STATE --
ANNA AND I AS I MENTIONED WE
DON'T HAVE TO LOOK TOO FAR TO
UNDERSTAND HOW URGENT THE
SITUATION IS WITH THE TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN SHOOTING DEATH.
UP NINE BLACK PARISHIONERS AT A
SOUTH CAROLINA CHURCH THE HANDS
OF A WHITE NATIONALISTS.
SO I. I BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE OUR SEARCH FOR RACIAL
HARMONY --
AND I THINK THAT IT WOULD TAKE A
BIG STEP FORWARD IF CONGRESS
WERE TO ACT. TO REMOVE THESE
RACIALLY DIVISIVE SYMBOLS FROM
ALL FEDERAL PROPERTIES.
MY HOPE THIS RESOLUTION INSPIRES
PEOPLE TO RE EXAMINE.
ANY AND ALL TIES AMERICA MAY
HAVE WITH THE CONFEDERACY AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU AND SENATE YOU
MENTIONED THE AMENDMENTS BUT
YOU'RE TAKING THOSE ABOUT A
CERTAIN PARTS IT TAKES US IN
THAT YES SIR THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH ME ON THIS RESOLUTION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I DON'T IN SUPPORT.
AND LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SAY NONE OF BRING BACK THE
COMMITTEE'S QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SO THERE IS A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
SORRY CLOSE THANKS YOUR
CONSIDERATION APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU.
SO THAT MOTION IS THAT AS YOU
ARE.
FOURTEENTH BE ADOPTED AS AMENDED
KALRA PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM CHAU.
CHOW AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE HOLDEN KALRA KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN REYES
[inaudible]
REYES I THAT NEEDS ONE MORE SO
WE WILL PUT THAT RESOLUTION ARE
CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU.
WE HAVE SENATOR WIENER STILL TO
GO HE'S SIGNED IN.
BUT IF WE COULD GET IN HERE WE
COULD GET DONE ALSO TAKE OF WE
HAVE ONE ITEM.
ON THE CONSENT AGENDA THAT IS
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AJ ARE THIRTY
NINE CHOI TAKE A MOTION.
THANK YOU.
SO WE DO HAVE MOTION AND A
SECOND ON THE CONSENT AGENDA
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE AYE
STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM CHOW.
CHOW AYE CHU.
CHU AYE HOLDEN KALRA KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN REYES
[inaudible]
REYES I THAT ALSO NEEDS ONE
MORE.
SO WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
WITHOUT ON CALL.
RIGHT UNTIL MR WINNERS A COUPLE
MINUTES OUT SO.
WE WILL WAIT
.
FOR SENATOR WIENER SO THAT TAKES
US TO OUR FINAL ITEM ITEM NUMBER
THREE S. YOUR ONE TED
.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
ARE YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR OUT
WORKING WITH US ON THIS
RESOLUTION --
AND I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES OPCODES AMENDMENT
SECURE --
WHICH WE BELIEVE RESULT IN
NUMBER THE ISSUES RAISED IN
OPPOSITION LETTER TO THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH US.
BUT I'M HONORED TO PRESENT
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
TEN OF WHICH RECOGNIZES
INTERSECTS CALIFORNIANS --
AS AN IMPORTANT PART OF OUR
STATES DIVERSITY.
CELEBRATED OUR WEB RATHER THAN
--
A CONSIDERED SOME SORT OF
ABERRATION IN NEED OF
CORRECTION.
APPROXIMATELY ONE IN EVERY TWO
THOUSAND BABIES --
IS BORN WITH EXTERNAL SEX
CHARACTERISTICS THAT ARE NOT
PERCEIVED AS WHAT WE TYPICALLY
DO IS MALE OR FEMALE --
SUCH A BABY WOULD BE CONSIDERED
ENTER SOCKS AND STANDARD MEDICAL
PRACTICE FOR MANY YEARS.
OF ALL THE MEDICAL PRACTICES
SHIFTED SOMEWHAT BUT STANDARD
MEDICAL PRACTICE HAS OFTEN BEEN.
UP TO ALMOST IMMEDIATELY PERFORM
--
INFANT SEX ASSIGNMENT SURGERY
GENITAL SURGERY UP TO CONFORM
THAT INFANT'S BODY TO STANDARD
NOTIONS OF MASCULINITY AND
FEMININITY.
WHETHER OR NOT THAT SURGERY IS
MEDICALLY NO.
MEDICAL NECESSITY FOR EXAMPLE
THE BABY CANNOT URINATE OR SOME
--
ADRENALYN BALANCE --
VERSES ARE NON MEDICALLY
NECESSARY ESSENTIALLY COSMETIC
SURGERY --
TO SAY WE'RE GOING.
TO MAKE YOU LOOK LIKE WHAT WE
PERCEIVE TO BE MALE OR A FEMALE
--
ASIDE FROM THE OBVIOUS RISK OF
GETTING ASSIGNED TO THE WRONG
GENDER --
BECAUSE OUR ALTHOUGH THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO THEN GROW UP AND DIE
GENDER ASSIGNMENT WAS TO BE A
GENDER WITH WHICH IDENTIFY.
THEIR PEOPLE WHO GROW UP AYE AND
IDENTIFY WITH A DIFFERENT UNDER.
ANOTHER BECOMES AN IRREVERSIBLE
I CHANGE THAT PERSON'S BODY THAT
THAT'S NOT.
INFORMED WITH THEIR OWN GENDER
IDENTITY.
ASIDE FROM THAT OBVIOUS RISK.
A THESE THE REVERSAL SURGERIES
CAN LEAD TO PERMANENT LOSS OF
SEXUAL SENSATIONS STERILIZATION
INCONTINENCE AND A VARIETY OF
SEVERE PSYCHOLOGICAL IMPACTS --
AT AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE ASKING
FOR WHAT THIS RESOLUTION STATES
IS THAT PEOPLE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
DECIDE FOR THEMSELVES WHETHER TO
HAVE THAT SURGERY.
SET UP FOR ME AT WHEN THEIR
BABY.
BUT IT'S NOT MEDICALLY
NECESSARY.
LET'S LET THESE.
KIDS DECIDE FOR THEMSELVES
EXPRESS THEIR VENDOR.
DECIDE IF THEY WANT TO HAVE THE
SURGERY IF THEY WANT TO TAKE --
THOSE RISKS --
THERE'S BEEN SOME DISCUSSION
ABOUT A CONGENITAL ADRENAL
HYPERPLASIA OR CA H. --
WHICH CAN CAUSE INTERSECTS
TRAITS --
INFANTS BORN WITH CA H.
GENERALLY REQUIRE A VARIETY OF
MEDICAL INTERVENTIONS. TO
PREVENT SEVERE HARM OR EVEN
DEATH FROM DANGEROUSLY LOW
LEVELS.
T. ADRENAL HORMONES --
AGAIN WE DON'T OPPOSE IN ANYWAY
TREATMENT FOR THAT MEDICAL
CONDITION.
INVASIVE GENITAL SURGERIES
HOWEVER IN NO WAY TREAT THAT
UNDERLYING CONDITION --
SO -- THIS
IS REALLY ABOUT ALLOWING PEOPLE
TO MAKE THEIR OWN CHOICES ABOUT
THEIR OWN BODIES --
AND ABOUT GIVING PEOPLE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS THEIR
GENDER RATHER THAN HAVING
PHYSICIANS.
I AM PARENTS --
WHEN THE CHILD AS A BABY --
MAKE THAT DECISION FOR THEM THAT
IRREVERSIBLE [inaudible]
I DECISION.
NOT SO WITH ME HERE TODAY.
ARE ELOQUENT --
AND INTERACT YOUTH MEMBER
INSECTS PERSON --
IRK LOWMAN AUTHOR OF THE BOOK
RAISING ROSY OUR STORY OF
PARENTING AND INTERCEPTS CHILD
--
AND A NOTE TO SOMEONE WILL BE
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS DOCTOR ARE LIAM AYE
PARROTS WHO SERVES ON THE BOARD
OF INTERACT --
AND OTHER ORGANIZATIONS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
MY NAME IS ALIQUIPPA I AM TWENTY
SIX AND I AM NON BINARY WHICH
MEANS THAT I DON'T IDENTIFY AS
MALE OR FEMALE I AM INTERSEX
PERSON WITH CONGENITAL ADRENAL
HYPERPLASIA.
I GREW UP HAPPILY WITHOUT
COSMETIC CLITORAL REDUCTION
SURGERY I HAVE A FORM OF CH
CALLED THREE BETA HST
I HAD NO PHYSICAL DIFFERENCE AT
BIRTH SO WE DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT IT
UNTIL I WAS SIX AT THAT AGE MY
BODY BEGIN DEVELOP MORE
TYPICALLY MASCULINE TRAITS.
BECAUSE OF THE GENITAL
DIFFERENCES I DEVELOPED MY
DOCTORS WANTED TO SURGICALLY
REDUCE THE SIZE OF MY* BY
THE WAY 39% OF PATIENTS IN ONE
STUDY WHO HAD THE SURGERY COULD
NOT ORGASM AS ADULTS.
THE DOCTORS WANTED TO MAKE THAT
DECISION FOR ME AS A SIX YEAR
OLD.
I GOT LUCKY MY MOM KNEW A
COSMETIC CLITORAL REDUCTION
WASN'T SOMETHING HER SIX YEAR
OLD NEEDED.
SHE TOLD THE DOCTORS NOW AND I
AM SO GRATEFUL.
BECAUSE MY MOM KNEW WHAT
QUESTIONS TO ASK IN BECAUSE SHE
WASN'T AFRAID OF RAISING A CHILD
WHOSE BODY WAS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT.
I WAS SAVED FROM AN INVASIVE NON
CONSENSUAL GENITAL SURGERY.
LOTS OF LOVING PARENTS MIGHT NOT
KNOW TO SPEAK UP BECAUSE THEY
WANT TO BELIEVE THE DOCTORS
WOULD ONLY ADVOCATE WHAT'S BEST
FOR THEIR CHILDREN.
MANY DOCTORS TELL PARENTS THAT
KIDS LIKE ME WILL BE BULLIED
VIRGIN LITTLE DIFFERENCES BUT
THEY HAVE NO DATA ON THIS
HYPOTHETICAL HARM.
AS A CA AGE TEAM LOCKER ROOM
CYMBELINE WITH THE LEAST OF MY
WORRIES COMPARED TO FUTURE
SEXUAL FUNCTION DOCTORS ARE
STILL OPERATING ON THEIR
ASSUMPTIONS INSTEAD OF LISTENING
TO INTERSEX PATIENTS LIKE ME.
THOSE OPPOSING AT SEA ARE ONE
TEN BROUGHT SOMEONE WHO WAS
HAPPY THAT SHE HAD A SURGERY AS
A YOUNG CHILD I'M GLAD THAT
WORKED OUT.
FOR IT DIDN'T WORK OUT FOR MY
FRIEND JOHNNY OR MY FRIEND AXLE
OR BRIAN A MAN WOULD SEE AGE WAS
WRONGLY ASSIGNED FEMALE AND HAD
GENITAL SURGERY REMOVING TISSUE
HOME NEVER GET BACK.
I'M HERE TODAY FOR THEM.
I COULD HAVE BEEN ANOTHER
INTERSEX PERSON SO YOU WOULD SEE
A AGE FORCED TO FIT INTO A
GENDER I'M NOT.
STUDIES SHOW ONE IN EIGHT OF US
WITH SEEDS DON'T IDENTIFY AS
GIRLS BUT THE OPPOSITION WANTS
TO PRETEND THAT WE DON'T EXIST
AND WHATEVER OUR GENDERS WE ALL
DESERVE THE CHANCE TO MAKE OUR
OWN CHOICES.
ABOUT COSMETIC GENITAL SURGERY.
I AM GRATEFUL FOR MY NATURAL AND
ALTERED INTERSEX BODY AND FOR
THIS RESOLUTION THAT SUPPORTS
OTHERS LIKE ME.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S WITNESS BUT MY
NAME IS ERIC WOMAN I MA
INTRACTABLE AND MEMBER.
A COLLEGE PROFESSOR AND I'M THE
PROUD FATHER OF INTERSEX
DAUGHTER WITH CONGENITAL GREETED
DRILL HYPERPLASIA.
EFFECT TODAY IS HER BIRTHDAY OUR
SIXTH BIRTHDAY I LEFT OUR FAMILY
VACATION HOW IN OHIO SO THAT I
COULD BE HERE BECAUSE I SO
STRONGLY BELIEVE.
ON THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
RESOLUTION.
AND I WOULD SECOND GIVE BIRTH TO
ROSY SIX YEARS AGO TODAY AND
THAT'S WHEN OUR EXPERIENCE --
PRESSURE PATHOLOGY ISING
OUTRIGHT LIES FROM THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY BEGAN.
YOU'RE ALL JUST TOLD US THAT
ROSY WOULD NEED SURGERY TO
CREATE A VAGINAL OPENING AND
SEPARATE THE URETHRA FROM THE
VAGINAL CANAL.
EVEN THOUGH ITTESTS THAT HAVE
BEEN CONDUCTED THE DAY BEFORE
SHOW THAT THERE WAS NORMAL
URINARY FUNCTION.
EVEN OFFERED TO COMBINE THE
SURGERY WITH THE COSMETIC
LITERAL REDUCTION SURGERY JUST A
WHILE SHE WAS UNDER THE
ANESTHETIC.
NOW THEY ONE DISORDER KILL TWO
BIRDS WITH ONE STONE THEY NEVER
PRESENTED NO SURGERY AS AN
OPTION TO US. SEVEN I HAD TO ASK
FORCEFULLY NEUROLOGISTS ABOUT
THAT POSSIBILITY.
AND HE SAID HE PURPOSELY DIDN'T
MENTION ARE DELAYING SURGERY
BECAUSE HE DIDN'T THINK IT WAS A
WORTHWHILE AVENUE.
EVEN THOUGH HER URINARY FUNCTION
WAS FIND EVEN ORTEZ APPROVING IT
THE DAY BEFORE.
HOT HE STILL INSISTED THAT
SURGERY WAS THE BEST OPTION.
EVEN A FEW MIGHT NEVER WANT TO
VAGINAL OPENING.
UP AND AT LEAST PROBABLY UNTIL
PUBERTY WOULD ONE BECOME
NECESSARY.
ANOTHER FAMILY LIKE OURS WITH --
DOT WITH THE AGE OF THE SIMILAR
STORY BOTH THE UROLOGIST AND
ROSIE'S UROLOGIST TRY TO
PRESSURE US INTO SURGERY.
USING CLAIMS THAT ARE SIMPLY
UNTRUE.
SUCH AS YOUR CHILD WILL HAVE
FREQUENT URINARY TRACT
INFECTIONS.
IT'S A VERY VERY COMMON IN FACT
UP FOR PARENTS OF C. H. GIRLS A
TO HEAR THIS CLAIM.
ROSIEIS SIX YEARS OLD HAS NEVER
HAD A URINARY TRACT INFECTION IS
ADONAL SURGERY.
ARE THE OTHER PARENTS WHO WERE
CLOSE WITH A ALSO HAS A FIVE
FOUR YEAR OLD DAUGHTER WHO'S
NEVER HAVE URINARY TRACT
INFECTION IN SPITE OF BEING TOLD
THIS WAS AN INEVITABILITY
MULTIPLE FUTURE HAS IN FACT
BECOME AND NOT ONLY HAVE.
NEITHER OF OUR GIRLS NEVER HAD
THE U. TI BUT THE RESEARCH OF
NEUROLOGISTS HAS PROVEN OVER AND
OVER AGAIN THAT.
LEFT UNTREATED.
THESE GIRLS ARE NOT PRONE TO YOU
TWO GUYS AND YET LOTS OF PARENTS
ARE STONE OF IMPRESSION THAT
THESE ARE COMMON [inaudible]
A IN FACT A UT I RISKY SHOWN
ONLY TO THESE GENTLE SURGERIES
SELF.
ARE ONLY AFTER THESE SURGERIES
TO GROWTH TYPICALLY HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THE I. URINARY
TRACT INFECTIONS.
THE OPPOSITION WILL TRY TO
CONFUSE THE ISSUE BY POINTING
OUT THE VERY REAL MEDICAL
CONCERNS FOR MANY FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN.
WITH C. H. AS THIS IS SUPPOSED
TO BE A REASON TO REJECT THE
RESOLUTION AND AS A PARENT OF A
US MULTI WITH CH I APPRECIATE.
THE DISTINCTION IN THE MEANT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN MEDICALLY
NECESSARY AND MEDICALLY
UNNECESSARY.
WELL YES I TAKE MEDICATION THREE
TIMES A DAY SHE WAS A MEDICAL
ALERT BRACELET EVERYWHERE THAT
SHE GOES WE HAVE TO CARRY AND
MURDER YOU SEE BAG OF INJECTIONS
AROUND.
EVERYWHERE THAT SHE GOES.
I IN FACT JUST WE'RE IN OHIO SHE
GOT SICK AND VOMITED AND WE'RE
AT A COTTAGE.
AND SO WE HAD TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO GIVE THIS MEDICATION WHERE
THE CLOSEST HOSPITAL WAS SENT US
INTO A FRENZY.
TURNS OUT SHE JUST IT TOO MANY
HOT DOGS BUT IT WAS STILL.
A VERY VERY.
CONCERNING EPISODES HAPPENS A
LOT WITH KIDS WITH CA AGE TO BE
VERY STRATEGIC WRAP UP.
THE FROTHY ONLY ETHICAL CHOICE
WE'RE PRESENTED WITH.
THIS OPTION WAS TO LET ROSY
DECIDE FOR HERSELF AND IT SEEMS
TO BE THE ARE ONLY REASONABLE
OPTION THAT WE COULD CONSIDER IF
THERE IS NO MEDICALLY NECESSARY
REASON FOR HER TO HAVE ANY.
SURGERY AND BY DEFINITION THIS
IS A COSMETIC PROCEDURE.
SO I CAME HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS RESOLUTION AND I HOPE.
THEY WILL PASS IT [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
X. WITNESS.
ALRIGHT ONLY.
TO ANYONE UP LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS [inaudible]
RESOLUTION.
YOU JUST GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION AND MY CHILD ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT.
JOHN MICHAEL FOR EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA WE'RE PROUD TO BE A
CO SPONSOR IN SUPPORT AND ALSO
LIKE TO STATE THE SUPPORT OF
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY NETWORK WHO
COULDN'T BE HERE TODAY THANK
YOU.
HINES LINDAHL FOR INTERACT
ADVOCATES FOR INFORMED CHOICE --
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IN ON US IN SUPPORT.
RIGHT SAY NONE OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
MORNING FANATIC.
SHARON STONE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
YOU TODAY REGARDING.
SCR.
ONE TEN MY NAME IS WAYNE PALMER
I'M A BOARD CERTIFIED PEDIATRIC
UROLOGISTS PRACTICING IN NEW
YORK IN CASE THAT HASN'T COME
THROUGH YET.
I'M ALSO THE PRESIDENT OF THE
SOCIETY FOR PEDIATRIC UROLOGY
WHICH IS THE PRIMARY
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING
AMERICAN PEDIATRIC UROLOGISTS WE
HAVE APPROXIMATELY SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MEMBERS. FIFTY OF COME
FROM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS FEW GREATLY APPRECIATES THE
WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE ON BEHALF
OF SCR OF ONE TEN TO HELP
CORRECT SOME OF THE INACCURACIES
THAT.
WERE PRESENTED INITIALLY BUT WE
REMAIN OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED
DUE TO THE FAILURE OF THE
RESOLUTION TO ADDRESS TWO
PRIMARY CONCERNS.
THE FIRST IS THAT TERMS LIKE
INTERSECTS WITH HERE'S THE ARE
INTENTIONALLY MEANT TO BE
BROUGHT.
BUT AS MORE INFORMATION COMES
LITERATURE AND OTHER --
LITERATURE IS A BECOMES CLEAR
THAT SOME DIAGNOSES JUST ARE.
MISS --
REPRESENTED INTO THE GORY OR IN
FACT STAND ON ITS OWN --
SHE EIGHT REPRESENTS 90% OF THE
CASES THAT WOULD BE IMPACTED BY
SIAKA SERE ONE TEN YET THE VAST
MAJORITY OF C. H. PATIENTS.
AND THE VAST MAJORITY OF MEDICAL
SPECIALISTS TO MANAGE PATIENTS
WITH C. H. DON'T CONSIDER IT
INTERSECTS.
BUT RATHER A METABOLIC DISORDER
OF THE OF THE ADRENAL GLAND
WHICH APARTMENT NATURE AND
EARLIER --
THE HIGH TESTOSTERONE LEVELS
WHICH MAY ALTER THE APPEARANCE
OF THE GONADS IS A RISK FOR SOME
OF THE PATIENTS HAVE C. H. BUT
NOT CLEARLY ALL OF THEM.
THIS IS AN ISSUE OF THE EXTERNAL
GENITALIA IT THAT'S NOT IMPACT
--
THE THE INTERNAL GENITALIA SO IN
OTHER WORDS THERE'S NO ISSUE
WITH THE OVARIES HAVE NO ISSUE
WITH UTERUS IF LOOKING IN TOMBS
TUBES THIS IS PRIMARILY AN
EXTERNAL GENITALIA ISSUE.
AND IN FACT IF DIAGNOSED EARLY
ENOUGH IN SELECT CASES IT CAN BE
MANAGED AND THE EFFECTS OF THE
TESTOSTERONE ARE NOT PRESENT AT
BIRTH.
THE SECOND ISSUE IS THAT MANY OF
THE ALLEGATIONS OR POP OR ROCK
COMMENTS STATED IN THE WHEREAS
SECTIONS OF THE RESOLUTION
REALLY REFLECT THAT AN ESTIMATE
AND ANACHRONISTIC VIEW OF THE
CURRENT STATE OF MEDICAL AFFAIRS
--
WHAT WE DO WHEN WE ENCOUNTER
PATIENTS AND FAMILIES WITH WITH
THE STD OR CA H.?
IS VERY DIFFERENT TODAY THAN IT
WAS BACK IN NINETEEN NINETY ONE
WHEN I STARTED MY PRACTICE OR
STARTED TRAINING.
TODAY WE HAVE A MULTI SPECIALTY
TEAM.
THE TEEMING CORPORATES
ADOLESCENT GYNECOLOGIST SOCIAL
WORKERS --
GENETICIST DEVELOPMENTAL FAR
BEHAVIORAL PEDIATRICIANS AS WELL
AS ENDOCRINOLOGIST IN PEDIATRIC
UROLOGIST BECAUSE THERE'S A
MULTITUDE OF ISSUES THAT EACH
SPECIFIC TRIAL HAS AND THEY
SHOULD BE ADDRESSED.
IN TURN BY THOSE WHO KNOW FROM A
MEDICAL STANDPOINT --
THE MOST ABOUT THE SPECIFIC
ISSUES SO THAT FAMILIES HAVE
ACCESS -- TO
EVIDENCE BASED INFORMATION NOT
ANECDOTAL INFORMATION REGARDING
WHAT MAY OR MAY NOT BE OPTIONS
FOR THEIR CHILD.
AND SURGERY REMAINS AN OPTION
IT'S NOT APPLY TO EVERYBODY ITS
SUPPLY JUDICIOUSLY AND FAMILIES
ARE SHOULD BE GIVEN ALL THE
INFORMATION SO THAT THEY IN THE
MEANTIME STILL HAVE THE RIGHT TO
MAKE DECISIONS FOR THEIR
CHILDREN.
THE ABILITY TO HAVE ALL THE
INFORMATION AVAILABLE TO THEM --
WE APPRECIATE THE THE EFFORTS ON
BEHALF INCLUDING THE AUTHOR OF
WORKING WITH US IN TRYING.
TO MAKE THIS RESOLUTION MORE
ACCURATE BUT AS A CURRENTLY
STATES -- WE
ARE OF HIS REMAIN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE RESOLUTION
UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND THANK YOU.
THAT'S WHAT A SWISS --
FOR FIRST ABOVE THANK YOU ALLEY
FOR SHARING YOUR STORY AND HAPPY
pA AND THANK YOU CHAIRMAN STONE
AND FELLOW MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE --
MY NAME IS ADRIAN MARKS AND I AM
A TWENTY SIX YEAR OWNERS FROM
NAPA CALIFORNIA.
AND THIS IS MY STORY OF
CONGENITAL ADRENAL HYPERPLASIA
OR CA EACH.
WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS A MY
BIRTH MY FAMILY'S JOY WAS
QUICKLY REPLACED WITH TRIPS TO
THE ICU AND FEAR. FOUR DAYS
LATER STANFORD DOCTORS TOLD MY
PARENTS WHAT.
I HAD CA H. A LIFE THREATENING
ADRENAL DISORDER REQUIRING DAILY
MEDICATION TO SURVIVE.
BECAUSE OF CA H. I WAS ALSO BORN
WITH MALFORMED EXTERNAL
GENITALIA BUT I WAS A GIRL.
IF NOT FOR THREE SUCCESSFUL
SURGERIES AT THE AGES OF ONE
FOUR AND SIXTEEN I WOULD HAVE
BEEN EMOTIONALLY TRAUMATIZED.
BE SURGERIES ALLOWED ME TO LIVE
AS A HEALTHY CHILD PREVENTED
CHRONIC URINARY INFECTIONS AND
TODAY I AM IN A LOVING LONG TERM
RELATIONSHIP.
AS A BISEXUAL FEMALE AND A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE LGBT
PLUS COMMUNITY I DO UNDERSTAND
THE IMPORTANCE FOR SCR.
ONE TEN HOWEVER SEE AGE IS NOT
SIMPLY AN LGBT MATTER BUT A LIFE
THREATENING MEDICAL CONDITION.
I A 100% SUPPORT GENDER
DIVERSITY BUT I CANNOT SUPPORT A
POLICY THAT WAS WRITTEN WITHOUT
CONSULTING THE LEADING EXPERTS
IN CA H. OR EVEN THE C. H.
COMMUNITY ITSELF.
BECAUSE OF THIS I WORRY FOR THE
FUTURE C. H. KIDS WHO MIGHT DIE
OF A SIMPLE URINARY INFECTION.
OR THE GIRL WHO WROTE THIS
LETTER A NINETEEN YEAR OLD
COLLEGE SOPHOMORE WHO STATED NOT
EVEN HER WORST ENEMY YOU SHOULD
SUFFER THE EMOTIONAL PAIN SHE
HASN'T HEARD TO NOT HAVING SIR
SURGERY EARLY ENOUGH --
I DO THINK CHAIRMAN STONE FOR
RECOGNIZING IN THE ANALYSIS
HOUSE CA H. IS DISTINCTLY
DIFFERENT FROM THE OTHER
CONDITIONS ADDRESSED IN SCR.
ONE TEN AS I'VE SHARED TODAY THE
VAST MAJORITY OF CA H. PATIENTS
DO HAVE POSITIVE OUTCOMES A
GENITAL SURGERY.
WE SEE THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY AS
LIFESAVERS AND NOT MONSTERS AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY WE ARE HAPPY.
FINALLY IF S. C. ARE ONE TEN IS
ABOUT PATIENTS USING THEIR VOICE
AND PLEASE LISTEN TO US.
ASKING TO HAVE A CHOICE IN THIS
VERY PERSONAL DECISION.
I URGE YOU ALL TO AMEND S. C. R.
ONE TEND TO CLEARLY EXCLUDE
CONGENITAL ADRENAL HYPERPLASIA
THINKING [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NO ONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
YOU COME FORWARD AND STATE YOUR
NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION
PLEASE.
THE NAME'S NICOLE GREENBERG AND
I'M THE GIRLFRIEND OF A DREAM
I'M FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND I
IDENTIFIES LGBTQ AND I OPPOSE.
DOCTOR ROGER DE FILIPPO
PEDIATRIC ARE ALL JUST HOLDS
HOSPITAL SAN JOS ALSO REPRESENT
CARES FOUNDATION I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS YEAR ONE TENTH.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
SEE ARE ONE TEN AND LINDA SHORT
LIFE PREVIOUS CHAIR AT TYPES OF
UROLOGY AT STANFORD UNIVERSITY
PEDIATRIC UROLOGIST.
I'M GENERALLY KORA PARENT OF A
CHILD WITH SO WASTING CONGENITAL
HYPERPLASIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
RESOLUTION.
SENATE AND MEL NAPA VALLEY
NEIGHBOR OF ADRIAN AND I POSTS
ARE RESOLUTION.
I'M ELIZABETH MARKS ADRIAN'S
MOTHER.
AND I I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
ESSAY ARE ONE TEN UNLESS AMENDED
TO EXCLUDE CA H..
I'M PETER MARKS FROM NAPA
CALIFORNIA ALSO THE FATHER OF
ADRIN MARKS AND I STRONGLY PROSE
AS SEE ARE ONE TEN AS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SIGNAL BRING IT BACK.
TO THE COMMITTEE CENTER THANK
YOU.
FOR TAKING THE AMENDMENTS WE'VE
HAD SOME DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THAT
HAVE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO TALK
TO THEIR PROPONENTS OF THE
OPPONENTS AND IN FACT WHEN TALK
TO QUITE A SEVERAL.
UROLOGISTS AND SURGEONS NONE OF
WHOM KNEW THAT THIS WAS
HAPPENING BECAUSE I WANTED TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND CA H. THE
IMPACT AND AND AND THE SPECTRUM
THAT IT REPRESENTS AND FROM MY
STANDPOINT.
I DO UNDERSTAND THE OPPOSITION
TO THIS BUT I THINK THIS
RESOLUTION AT THIS POINT IS.
IS A REASONABLY FAIR STATEMENTS
ALTHOUGH I THINK THE AT THE
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE ADDRESSED
IF IF THIS STATEMENT IS GOING TO
TURN INTO POLICY FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
SOME DEFINITIONS NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED LIKE.
THE AGE OF CONSENT WOULD NEED TO
BE TALKED ABOUT THE MEDICAL
NECESSITY AND AND SOME OF THE
REAL DIFFERENCES.
WITHIN THIS SPECTRUM OF OF CA H.
I SORT OF FIND WITHOUT BEING A
MEDICAL EXPERT AND I APPRECIATE
THE TIME THAT.
ALL OF THE PHYSICIANS HAD SPENT
WITH ME TO TRY AND BRING ME UP
TO SPEED ON ON SOME OF THIS IT'S
CH IS IS REALLY A SPECTRUM THAT
PRESENTS.
DIFFERENT PHYSICAL ATTRIBUTES.
FOR EACH OF THE PATIENTS AS WELL
AS THE SIGNIFICANT ADRENAL
COMPLICATIONS THAT ARE THAT ARE
THERE THAT THAT DO REQUIRE SOME
MEDICAL ASSISTANCE I THINK
CERTAINLY HAS THAT AS A SENATOR
POINTED OUT.
SO IT IT DEFTLY RAISES SOME
QUESTIONS BUT THAT THE THE
INTENTION OF ENSURING.
THAT CHILDREN HAVE THE BEST
DECISIONS POSSIBLE THAT THEY'RE
ENGAGED IN THOSE DECISIONS THAT
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO DEVELOP
THEIR IDENTITY.
AS THEY ARE BORN AND AS THEY
FEEL IS REALLY WHAT I SEE ARE
ONE TEN IS IS ABOUT.
AND AS I'VE TALKED ABOUT THE
OPPONENTS AND THE PROPONENTS.
EVERYBODY ENDS UP SAYING PRETTY
MUCH THE SAME THAT.
THE QUESTION REALLY COMES DOWN
TO THE SPECIFICS OF CA H. THE
SPECTRUM THAT IT PRESENTS AND
THE DECISIONS THAT PARENTS AND
PHYSICIANS FACE.
IN EFFECT NONE OF THE PHYSICIANS
THAT I TALK.
TO WERE INCLINED IN THIS IS A
CASE A SUBSET I WILL ADMIT AND A
SUBSET IN SORT OF MY AREA.
NONE OF THEM WOULD BE INCLINED
TO RECOMMEND SURGERY BECAUSE
THEY RECOGNIZE THAT THAT'S A
SIGNIFICANT STEP NOW THAT MAY
NOT BE THE ANSWER.
ACROSSCALIFORNIA ARE CERTAINLY
ACROSS THE COUNTRY THAT
SOMETHING AGAIN WORTHY OF
DISCUSSION HERE.
BUT IT SEEMS THAT [inaudible]
PHYSICIANS ARE MORE INCLINED TO
WANT TO WORK TOGETHER AND IN
TEAMS WON A CASE PRESENTS ITSELF
PROVIDE THE BEST INFORMATION
POSSIBLE TO THE PARENT TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE SOME OF THOSE
DECISIONS.
AND THEN HOPEFULLY GIVE THAT
CHILD THE CHANCE TO DEVELOP. FOR
HIS OR HERSELF AND IN THEIR OWN
IDENTITY AND AND THEIR OWN
PHYSICAL ATTRIBUTES BEFORE
IRREVERSIBLE CHANGES ARE MADE
AND TO ME THAT'S REALLY WHAT S.
YOUR ONE TEN STANDS.
FOR THIS WHY I'M SUPPORTING ITS
ASK EVERYONE HERE TO SUPPORT IT
BUT WITH THE CAUTION AND AGAIN
THE ANALYSIS POINTS OUT THAT IF
THIS IS GOING TO MOVE TO POLICY.
THERE ARE SOME SIGNIFICANT
QUESTIONS THAT THAT WILL NEED TO
BE ANSWERED THIS IS A STATE
WHERE THE LEGISLATURE IT IS NOT
A STATEMENT OF POLICY BUT IS
TAYLOR PLEDGES OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
SO IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE TRY TO
GET IT AS RIGHT AS WE CAN.
AND WILL BE ABLE TO MOVE THIS
THROUGH.
SO OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
[inaudible]
COMMITTEE MEMBERS [inaudible]
ISRAEL.
MISTER CHAIR I DO APPRECIATE ALL
THAT NOT THAT YOU DID IN THIS
PARTICULAR BILL --
THAT IS THE RESOLUTION IT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
UNDERSTAND THAT WE KNOW THAT
THIS IS A RESOLUTION AS OPPOSED
TO POLICY.
AND I WOULD AGREE WITH YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT SHOULD THIS
MOVE FORWARD TO POLICY THAT IT
IS SOMETHING THAT I I I I TAKE
THE THAT YOUR COMMENTS VERY
SERIOUSLY.
AND WOULD WANT THAT TO BE
INCLUDED BUT FOR TODAY I WOULD
MOVE THE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU SO WE DO HAVE A
MOTION.
AND THE SECOND CHIU.
OTHERS HAD IN ADDITION TO A
SECOND IN THE MOTION THAT I
APPRECIATE THAT THE AUTHOR.
I HAS ACKNOWLEDGED IN THE
RESOLUTION THAT THIS IS REALLY
FOCUSED ON MEDICALLY UNNECESSARY
PROCEDURES I THINK BOUT HAS BEEN
A BIT OF A COMMON --
MISUNDERSTANDING ABOUT WHAT THIS
RESOLUTION IS ABOUT A AND A VERY
MUCH RESPECT THE PERSPECTIVE OF
THE OPPOSITION PARTICULARLY
FROM.
THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY BUT I
THINK -- FOR
ALL OF US FOR TALKING ABOUT A
MEDICALLY UNNECESSARY PROCEDURE
I KNOW THERE'S MIGHT BE SOME.
DIFFERENCES ON WHAT THAT ENTAILS
BUT IF THAT'S WERE TALKING ABOUT
--
THE IDEA OF NOT ALLOWING --
STRIKES ME AS ONE THAT WE
SHOULDN'T SUPPORT SO WITH THAT
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE REST OF
THANK YOU ANYONE UP.
RIGHT SIGNIN SENATOR YOU MAY
QUOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SHOT MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND AS I'M NOT GETTING
ACCUSTOMED TO COME IN THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE HAVING PER
THOUGHTFUL CONVERSATION
SEVERANCE APPRECIATE THAT --
COLLEAGUES AND WE ARE --
I DO KNOW THAT AT THIS
ULTIMATELY MOVES OUT TO BILL
OBVIOUSLY THERE WOULD BE IN A
LOT OF WORK THAT HAS TO BE DONE
WE KNOWLEDGE OUT BUT I THINK IT
IS.
IMPORTANT AND SIGNIFICANT FOR US
TO TAKE THIS STEP LOTS OF IT
THIS IS A REAL ISSUE --
THERE MAY BE DISAGREEMENTS
WITHIN THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY --
WITH AND THE INTERSEX.
POINTS OF VIEW I ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT IT WILL MAKE CLEAR THIS
ISN'T ABOUT ANYWAY DEMONIZING
THE MEDICAL PROFESSION AND THIS
ISN'T ABOUT SAYING DOCTORS --
YOU KNOW MONSTERS ARE THERE
ANYTHING ELSE I THINK IN A WAY
EVEN THOUGH THE MEDICAL
PROFESSION OBVIOUSLY IS FOCUSED
ON MEDICINE.
MEDICAL PROFESSION LIKE EVERY
OTHER PROFESSION ON EARTH
REFLECTS SOCIETY.
OJ AT SOCIETY CHANGES AND
EVOLVES NOTES IN THE MEDICAL
PROFESSION OF BALD TREMENDOUSLY
AROUND.
LGBT ISSUES WHERE IT USED TO BE
A WITH A MENTAL ILLNESS OUGHT TO
BE LGBT AND OUT SOCIETY ABOUT.
THE MEDICAL PROFESSION OF ALL
AND IT'S OF A PUSH AND PULL AND
SOMETIMES WE AS POLICY MAKERS.
NEED TO PUSH THE MEDICAL
PROFESSION WE DID AROUND
CONVERSION THERAPY WITHOUT IT ON
OTHER ISSUES --
AS WELL.
AYE AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE DIALOGUE WE HAVE WORKED
YOU KNOW.
WITH THE MEDICAL PROFESSION
THOUGHTS DOT CMA HAS REMOVED THE
TOP POSITION BASED ON AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE TAKEN AND WILL
CONTINUE TO DIALOGUE WITH THE
PROFESSION.
AND WITH THE COMMUNITY SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND THE
MOTION IS THAT THE RESOLUTION BE
ADOPTED AS AMENDED.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY
STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM CHAU.
CHAU AYE CHU.
CHU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE RADIUS
[inaudible]
REYES I THAT IS ADOPTED THANK
YOU BY THIS COMMITTEE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
RIGHT LET'S SELECT.
GO THROUGH AND WILL START WITH
CONSENT TO LET PEOPLE AT ON CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA.
KALRA AYE MAIENSCHEIN MENTION I
THANK YOU THAT HAD BETTER CALL A
LIFT TO THE CALL THAT THAT IS
NOW OUT THAT IS EIGHT YEAR.
THIRTY NINE BY SOME MEMORY CHOI
STARTING WITH ITEM. ONE THEN ACR
TWO SIXTY LOW IS ON KALRA LIFT
THE CALL.
CUNNINGHAM HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I THAT
BILL THEIR THEIR RESOLUTION IS
OUT ITEM NUMBER TO AJ ARE FORTY
TWO BY KAMLAGER-DOVE ON CALLING
LIFT THE CALL.
CUNNINGHAM HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
KALRA.
KALRA AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I THAT IS ADULTS
NUMBER I RIVER THREE WE DID I
NUMBER FOUR IS ON CALL US YEAR
FOURTEEN GLAZER I WILL LIFT THE
CALL.
CUNNINGHAM HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I THAT IS OUT ITEM
NUMBER SIX WHICH WAS PULLED FROM
CONSENT AJ ARE I'M SORRY H. R.
ONE THIRTEEN RUBIO ON THE LIST
THE CALL.
CUNNINGHAM HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE MAIENSCHEIN MENTIONED
I THANK YOU THAT CONCLUDES OUR
BUSINESS FOR TODAY THIS IS.
PROBABLY OUR LAST HEARING SO
WANT TO THANK.
MEMBERS FOR BEING HERE ALTHOUGH
EVERYBODY'S BAILED AT THIS POINT
WE HAD A WE HAD A LOT OF
HEARINGS AND A AND A LONG YEAR
NOW I SPECIFICALLY WANT TO THANK
STAFF. FOR THE NUMBER OF BILLS
FOR THE WORK THAT THEY DID.
SUGGEST FOR WORKING WITH US
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH
OUR COLLEAGUES ACROSS THE AISLE
THIS IS BEN.
I DARE SAY IT WILL KNOCK ON WOOD
BECAUSE THEY'RE STILL COUPLE
WORKS WEEKS LEFT BUT A A SMOOTH
YOU'RE FRIGID.
DISTRICT WE ACTUALLY SMOOTH
COUPLE YEARS I GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE PARTICIPATION OF
MEMBERS OF STAFF AND EVERYONE
HERE SO.
THANK YOU AND ON WE GO TO FLOOR